(electronic beeps)
(energetic music)
- This is our...
opening of our symposium today
sponsored by our local Kavli
Institute for Brain and Mind,
which is very generously
supported by the Kavli Foundation.
There are a variety of these institutes
that are around the country
and the unique Southern
California version of this is
as you can see our KIBM,
bridges disciplinary boundaries
to further understanding
of the origins, evolution, and
mechanisms of human cognition
relating neural mechanism to behavior.
I'm fortunate to share the
directorship with Nick Spitzer
and our Co-Director Ralph Greenspan.
So in addition to the support
from the Kavli Foundation,
in this aggregate underneath the KIBM
is the Center for Brain Activity Mapping,
and the California Brain:
a Neurotechnology Program of California,
and the San Diego Brain Consortium,
all of which Ralph has been
organizing and putting together
and we've aggregated
them under a single head
though they have independent functions
and activities throughout the year.
In general, the Kavli Foundation has been
as I said very generously
supporting research.
They are dedicated to
the advances of science.
Fred Kavli's vision was a
dedication to advanced science
and benefit of humanity,
promoting public understanding
of scientific research,
and support of scientists and their work.
It's a real international program.
They have five major
areas that they focus on
including astrophysics,
theoretical physics,
nanoscience, and neuroscience.
And in addition to meetings and institutes
that are supported by the Foundation
there are a series of prizes
that are given on a regular basis
that I think some of
you are familiar with.
The president of that
organization is Bob Conn
who we've known for a while.
Miyoung Chun is the
Executive Vice President
of Science Programs,
and James Cohen is the
Director of Communications.
We have two representatives,
Chris Martin and Syl Albin
are here representing the Kavli Foundation
and will be participating
today and in tomorrow's meeting
so thanks very much for coming.
I want to start by acknowledging
some of the people that have
really made this happen.
This is our, we call our KIBM staff
but really as some of you can see
that attend these regularly
this is sort of a hybrid
of our CARTA meetings
together with our KIBM meetings.
So, Ingrid Benirschke-Perkins,
Rachel Emens,
Kate Kaya, Kristen Michener, Linda Nelson,
Jesse Robie and Janet Shin.
We're being filmed, well,
I'm being filmed currently
but speakers will be filmed by UCSD-TV
and that'll be able to be
visualized at a later time point
in a modified version.
Rich Wargo is the Science
Producer, Matt Alioto is...
and Marci Bates and Jacob
Parker make this happen.
I'm very happy to introduce
Kent Schnoeker and Mike Jeffs
who are our local soft media folks.
So we have two...
Nick and I generally
search out two experts
in a field of interest
that we've identified
to help put together
an outstanding program
and we were lucky enough to have
Jennifer Lippincott-Schwartz
and Mark Ellisman
to agree to put together this
unusually good meeting today
and they will be chairing
the first and second session
which are, you have the
programs in your hand.
So without any further ado,
I'm going to ask Jennifer to come up
and give us just a very
brief introduction to the,
our title and our objectives
and then she'll chair the session.
Jennifer?
- Thank you very much, Rusty.
And I just wanna say how
delighted Mark Ellisman and I are
to have the opportunity to
co-chair this symposium today.
I mean it was a real delight
and we heard from Rusty and
Nick that we were chosen to pick
out of the whole world the
people who really define
this field of imaging
brain and neurobiology.
So that way that Mark, and Mark,
why don't you come over just
so that everybody can see.
This is my...
- Can I get close to you?
- Sure. (audience laughs) Exactly.
So, the way Mark and I really
went about choosing people
to be part of this symposium
was to cross scales of imaging
from looking at the
ultra-structure of brain slices,
to an intermediate level where
one's looking at organelles
and intercellular communication
all the way up to tissue
and brain in-vivo imaging.
We've also invited people who analyze
these data sets, these huge data sets
from the in-vivo brain imaging experiments
and finally, and in many
ways most importantly,
we've invited two
scientists who are pioneers
in the development of tools
that all of us are using
for doing this type of
imaging of the brain.
(upbeat music)